bonjour johanna rolland merci beaucoup
d'être notre invité avec plaisir un
matin vous êtes maire socialiste de
nantes présidente de france urbaine
c'est l'association qui regroupe les
métropoles les grandes villes et puis
vous êtes la directrice de campagne
d'anne hidalgo tant de sujets dont on va
parler avec vous en étant 100 pendant 20
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale représenté par votre presse
régional ouest-france - stéphane bern
est bonjour bonjour et on va évidemment
parler de la situation en ukraine alors
que le pays est toujours sous les
bombardements qu'on apprend ce matin qui
à 60 km de blindés en approche de la
capitale kiev est ce que ça veut dire
que les solutions diplomatiques ne
marche pas johanna rolland ça veut dire
que il faut les continuer même si à
l'évidence à ce stade elle ne suffisent
pas ce qui se passe aujourd'hui en
ukraine est un crime un crime contre la
paire qui me contre le peuple ukrainien
et crime contre la liberté un crime
contre notre sécurité intérieure et face
à cela la voix de l'europe doit être
tout à la fois unis vont continuer sur
le chemin qui a été emprunté et aussi
sans faiblesse ce qu'elle est pour vous
aujourd'hui je crois que celles et ceux
qui espéraient et sans doute de la dirm
il continue au premier chef avoir
finalement des responsables divisés
ont commis une erreur l'europe fait la
démonstration que dans ce temps
extrêmement grave elle est capable de
parler d'une voix unie d'une voie
efficace
c'est vrai sur les sanctions économiques
qui ont été prononcés c'est vrai anne
hidalgo la saluer hier à la sortie de la
réunion c'est le premier ministre y
compris sur la contribution à la
livraison d'armes je crois qu'on est
dans un moment extrêmement grave on a
peut-être oublié à quel point l'europe
était synonyme de paix est aujourd'hui
l'europe est contrainte à prendre ses
responsabilités c'est absolument
indispensable nous nous le devons aux
ukrainiens mais nous le devons au delà
parce que nous devons impérativement
arrêter l'entreprise mené aujourd'hui
par l'admin côté on va revient sur
comment on peut l'arrêter mais ce que
l'union européenne a trouvé un second
souffle
est-ce qu'elle s'est révélé quelque part
dans sa vie on écrème savez françois
mitterrand dans son dernier discours au
congrès de 95 disait le nationalisme
c'est la guerre est invité quelque part
par ces mots à la fois plus d'europe à
mieux d'europe je fais partie de ceux
qui pensent qu'on a besoin d'une europe
plus démocratique d'une europe plus
sociale du nord plus écolo aussi je le
dis dans ce moment où le rapport du giec
quand même fait partie de ce qui doit
continuer à nous interpeller
nous pensons avec anne hidalgo que nous
avons aussi besoin d'une europe de la
défense et on voit bien c'est aussi une
part de cette question géopolitique qui
se joue en ce moment comment est-ce
qu'on peut agir au niveau individuel ou
au niveau des collectivités par exemple
de présidente de france urbaine est ce
que vous allez prendre des initiatives
le drapeau ukrainien flotte au dessus de
la mairie de nantes est-ce qu'on peut
aller plus loin je crois qu'il ya de
rugy s'il ya le registre du symbolique
c'est la question des drapeaux c'est la
question de nos grandes places nos
grands monuments qui sont illuminés aux
couleurs de l'ukraine et je crois que
c'est important parce que c'est dire aux
ukrainiennes et aux ukrainiens que nous
sommes avec eux que notre pays choisis
toujours le camp de la liberté et puis
ensuite il y à l'aide concrète l'aide
concrète c'est se dire disponibles pour
accueillir des réfugiés ma ville le fait
mais de bien nombreuses autres villes le
font et effectivement au sein de france
urbaine avec jean luc moudenc le premier
vice président et puis l'ensemble des
membres nous allons très prochainement
et changer de cette capacité que nous
pour avoir peut-être à contribuer
compris à coordonner certaines
initiatives de ville je pouvais changer
ça veut dire quoi dans le moment on a
besoin de sang froid et on a besoin
d'ordre pardon de le dire de cette
manière parce que les bonnes volontés
c'est bien mais il faut qu'on puisse
être sûr que ce soit utile les premiers
échanges qu'on a avec les ukrainiens par
exemple nous disent que c'est pas
forcément tant de vêtements de
nourriture qu'il y aurait besoin c'est
plus de médicaments c'est plus de
contributions à des financements pour
que eux mêmes je pense aux acteurs
associatifs puisse s'organiser c'est
aussi essentiel dans ce moment de ne pas
penser à la place de mai de penser avec
celles et ceux qui sont les premiers
concernés
par exemple vous avez accueilli combien
de réfugiés pour l'instant pour
l'instant nous avons dit à l'état que
nous étions disponibles nous n'avons pas
encore de personnes pour lui du
ministère des affaires étrangères ni
celui de l'inter c'est essentiel en ce
moment que les collectivités locales et
l'état travaillent main dans la main
vous savez je ne partage pas c'est le
cas bien sûr dans ce moment ça l'est et
je crois que c'est essentiel vous savez
je ne partage pas l'orientation
politique de ce gouvernement mais je
considère nous considérons la famille
politique à laquelle j'appartiens anne
hidalgo don je dirige aujourd'hui la
campagne que l'heure est à l'unité
nationale parce que le moment est
suffisamment grave pour que nous
puissions venir soutenir toute
initiative positive il n'en demeure pas
moins que quand vladimir poutine attaque
l'europe c'est aussi la démocratie
qu'ils attaquent et donc la démocratie
doit continuer et donc le dialogue doit
continuer et donc le débat doit
continuer mais concrètement est ce que
les associations d'élus dont deux
parties vont discuter avec l'état pour
qu'il ait une répartition ces réfugiés
sur le territoire est ce que c'est ça
que vous êtes en train de mettre en
place ou pas ce que nous sommes en train
de mettre en place ces de recenser pour
l'instant quelles sont les villes les
communes les territoires mais aussi les
départements les régions qui sont prêts
à contribuer à cet accueil ensuite il
appartiendra à l'union européenne et à
l'état d'organiser d'un point de vue
logistique j'allais dire les choses non
feinte urbaine tous les biais de son
prêt tout il ya des villes qui vous
disent non nous sommes aujourd'hui en
train de finaliser d'engager les
discussions je ne connais pas
aujourd'hui de ville qui aurait dit non
mais je le redis nous sommes au début
pas de précipitation du sang froid et de
la réactivité nous sommes déjà un
certain nombre de grandes villes à dire
nous sommes disponibles quand vous
entendez d'eric zemmour le candidat eric
zemmour dire qu'il est de réfugiés
l'ukrainien devrait rester en pologne
comme ça ils pourront rentrer plus
facilement chez eux une fois que la
guerre sera terminé vous comprenez ou
comment est ce que vous entendez ça ses
propos sont à vomir
pardon mais pour moi y'a pas d'autres
réactions j'espère que
la gravité extrême de ces propos va
ouvrir les yeux de celles et ceux qui
pouvaient être tentés par l'imposture
eric zemmour cette extrême droite qui a
contribué de manière servile à relayer
la propagande de vladimir poutine depuis
des années ces hommes qui se déclare
toujours plus patriote plus français les
uns que les autres qui en réalité depuis
des années joue contre l'intérêt
national joue contre la construction
européenne joue contre nos valeurs les
plus démocratiques et aujourd'hui aux
dires ose dire quand on voit les images
encore cette nuit et ce matin du
craignaient les ukrainiens qui disent la
fierté de leur pays qui disent qu
évidemment qui plus est ils rentreront
chez eux demain et quand bien même et
quand bien même ils voudraient venir en
france et s'y intégrer c'est l'honneur
de notre pays d'être la patrie des
droits de l'homme
monsieur zemmour est tout sauf un
républicain il fait pas honneur à notre
pays aujourd'hui pour vous c'est pire
que ça c'est pire que du déshonneur
c'est bafouer les valeurs de notre pays
mais c'est mettre en danger la sécurité
des françaises et des français
l'efficacité de ce que nous sommes son
manque de clairvoyance sur le rapport à
monsieur poutine ça vaut pour lui comme
ça vaut pour marine le pen est un acte
extrêmement grave extrêmement grave que
ça vaut laisser parler de tendance
depuis trois jours qui change quoi que
ce soit à la faire voter jean luc
mélenchon sur ce sujet franchement il
s'est fourvoyé hier il se fourvoie
aujourd'hui regardez ses propos sur
l'allemagne quand même regarder ses
propos sur l'allemagne sincèrement je
crois profondément la présidence de la
république impose une autre dignité il
est discrédité aujourd'hui pour vous
dans cette campagne dans les planches où
je le crois oui clairement parce que ça
va se traduire dans l'est dans les
sondages ou dans l'est dans les urnes
sondages parce que pour l'instant si
vous êtes bien placé permettez-moi de le
dire à ouest france puisque vous avez
pris cette décision particulièrement
honorable je trouve de dire que le débat
public ne pas s'enfermer dans la
surenchère permanente des sondages pour
dire que pour le moment d'indicateur
concrets qui montrent que finalement les
gens prendraient conscience du décalage
sur troy bolton quoi crois que c'est un
peu tôt aujourd'hui les français ils
sont dans quoi ils sont dans le choc
qu'est ce qu'ils nous disent moi les
nantaises et les nantais quand je les
vois sur le terrain quand ils m'écrivent
qu'est ce qu'il me dise me disent qu'ils
sont choqués la phrase que j'ai entendu
le plus souvent ces derniers jours c'est
il y a une copine est maintenant il ya
la guerre et françaises et les français
ils ont besoin d'être rassurés ils ont
besoin ou d'une femme une femme je le
souhaite d'état capable d'assumer une
stature internationale capable de dire
sans transiger quel à la direction que
nous devons prendre je forme en revanche
le veut après tout ce début de campagne
kkm était de piètre qualité avec ce côté
le bruit et la fureur la surenchère de
la petite phrase une forme d'hystérie
nations du débat public je peux formé le
voeu que cette situation dramatique
amène enfin à reposer les vrais sujets
prenez le pouvoir d'achat c'est un sujet
qui est là depuis des mois on sait que
la situation internationale va le
ramener c'est pour cette raison qu anne
hidalgo a proposé le gel sur les prix de
l'énergie a proposé une tva abaissée sur
tous les produits de première nécessité
protéger les français et amener des
réponses concrètes il est grand temps
qu'un débat projet contre projet
proposition est-ce qu'il faut prendre
des nouvelles des valeurs bien sûr bur
en flandre alors que la guerre en
ukraine n'a pas encore produit ses
effets sur les prix à la pompe à ce que
vous demandez ce maintien au
gouvernement des mesures en juin est ce
que l'état va continuer à percevoir des
taxes en hausse puisque les prix sont en
hausse quand les françaises et les
français n'en peuvent plus le nombre de
gens qui nous disent qu'à partir du 22
du mois pour eux c'est compliqué d'abord
je me permets de le dire quand même la
question de la lutte contre la pauvreté
d'une manière générale a quand même été
le point aveugle de la politique de ce
gouvernement mais là on en est même plus
là on en est j'allais dire aux français
moyens si je dis les choses de manière
simple pour qui les sujets de pouvoir
d'achat sont compliquées quand on disait
ça au mois d'octobre parce que n'ayons
pas la mémoire trop courte quand anne
hidalgo la première a dit hausse des
prix des carburants
situation exceptionnelle mesures
exceptionnelles
je demande la baisse de la tva s'est
passé presqu'inaperçu s'est passé
presque décalé quelques mois après ce
sujet est au coeur de l'actualité le job
des responsables politiques c'est pas de
courir avec trois mois de retard pour
répondre aux aspirations profondes du
pays alors plutôt que de nous avoir
bassiné pendant des semaines sur le
prénom de nos enfants on aurait bien
fait collectivement de s'occuper des ja
du sujet du pouvoir d'achat parce que
derrière sa crise mme derrière ça
inquiète derrière ça rajoute de la
augmentation du pays et au delà même
l'échéance de l'élection présidentielle
je fais partie des responsables
politiques qui considèrent que cette
idée d'une république qui deviendrait de
plus en plus fragmenté et un des dangers
graves de notre pays on a besoin de
réconcilier les français les uns avec
les autres on a besoin de retrouver du
lien mais si le quotidien est trop
pénible si le quotidien est trop
douloureux eh bien ça devient
extrêmement compliqué georges en rien la
situation à la crise internationale vous
disais à l'instant on a besoin de deux
d'homme ou de femme qui est de ceux des
stades de vraie stature de chef d'état
est ce que vous pensez que c'est le
cadre d' anne hidalgo totalement elle
serait elle serait en capacité de gérer
une crise comme celle là c'est les
imprimantes ont peu
apprécié au journal qu il fait aucun
l'ombre d'un doute que son courage sa
ténacité
son histoire personnelle sa réaction
même dans cette campagne le monde je
n'ai pas si vous avez eu l'occasion
d'écouter le discours qu'elle a prononcé
à bordeaux sur l'ukraine
sincèrement toutes celles et tous ceux
que je connais soit qu'ils étaient soit
qu'il n'a entendu 10 il y avait là une
femme d'état et je pense que c'est
important je pense que ça l'est parce
que dans le moment dans lequel on est
quand on a des sujets aussi graves sur
la table que l'annoncent par poutine de
relever d'un cran les sujets nucléaire
on doit bien réfléchir à qui on confie
les clés de notre pays mais alors je le
dis à celles et ceux qui nous écoutent
et qui sont tentés par l'abstention
aujourd'hui parce qu'ils sont nombreux
je le redis ne restez pas à la maison ne
laissez pas décider l'avenir de rhdp
mais aussi votre avenir celui de vos
enfants dans un monde tel qu'il est
aujourd'hui regarder à qui vous allez
confier les clés justement ce discours
de bordeaux vous me dîtes si je me
trompe il a été totalement changé à la
dernière pour en faire un discours de
soutien aux ukrainiens ce que c'est pas
la preuve que la campagne ne pourra pas
désormais se tenir normalement et que
les thèmes de campagne que vous
souhaitiez imposer le pouvoir d'achat la
pauvreté bien nous ne réussirons pas
s'imposer dans cette campagne est-ce que
ça c'est pas un point négatif
électoralement pour vous peu importe en
fait vous rendez compte l'indécence qui
lui aurait à dire ah bah mince on doit
changer notre stratégie de campagne
parce qu'il ya la guerre en ukraine peu
importe le sujet c'est notre
responsablité notre responsabilité c'est
de dire notre soutien aux ukrainiens
notre responsabilité c'est de soutenir
toute initiative utile du gouvernement
sans esprit polémique sans esprit
partisan notre responsabilité c'est
évidemment de transformer totalement la
campagne c'est la raison pour laquelle
le meeting de bordeaux s'est transformé
en monde soutien aux ukrainiennes et aux
ukrainiens mais je le redis quand
poutine posta qu'ils attaquent la
démocratie donc notre responsabilité à
nous françaises et français c'est de
dire debout et bien non la démocratie va
continuer bien sûr qu'elle va continuer
différemment bien sûr que le débat va
être marquée par ses sujets du point de
vue extérieur mais je le redis du point
de vue intérieure l'augmentation des
prix la conséquence de ce qui se passe
en ukraine sur l'augmentation d'un
certain nombre de tarifs énergie et blé
par exemple pour ne citer que ceux là
les questions de souveraineté du pays
comment l'europe et la france résistent
au chantage russe sur le gaz par exemple
pour prendre ce sujet même si on sait
que la situation de la france et de
l'allemagne sont un peu différentes bien
sûr que tout ça mais forêt mais on n'a
pas envie de se rassembler derrière le
chef et le chef à l'heure actuelle c'est
emmanuel macron je les dis avec anne
hidalgo nous pensons que l'heure est à
l'unité nationale elle a été très clair
sur ce sujet ça fait partie d'ailleurs
de ce que j'évoquais sur la hauteur de
la femme d'état de stature
internationale qu'elle est ça n'empêche
pas de dire sur de nombreux autres
sujets l'éducation le climat la pauvreté
la lutte contre la précarité l'accès à
la santé le logement les trois urgences
qu'elle a développé dans notre programme
piloté par mathieu klein notamment le
maire de nancy comment sur l'urgence
sociale sur le genre écologique sur le
jeu démocratique nous avons des
propositions à faire les deux ans que la
région dix ans a déclaré manuel mâcon
pour vous malgré la situation
internationale il faut que le débat
présidentiel écoutez moi j'ai j'ai pas
envie de rentrer dans discussion
polémique sur ce sujet il est à sa tâche
de président ça me paraît bien normal le
temps du débat va venir soyons clairs
cherchons la concorde nationale sur tout
ce qui relève de l'ukraine et de
l'international et faisons vivre le
débat pas pour savoir est ce que ce sera
un meeting à marseille à paris ce que ce
sera le 5 ou le 6 franchement les
françaises et les français que je crois
c'est pas de ça dont il parle met face à
la gravité de la situation est ce
qu'elle est ce qu'on peut encore avoir
une campagne électorale en campagne la
semaine vous dites on va l'adapter et c
est ce que c'est possible est ce que les
gens vont être à l'écouté je crois que
vous avez évoqué les propos de monsieur
zemmour tout à l'heure quand même les
françaises et les français doivent
savoir à qui ils vont confier les
destinées du pays donc oui on doit
trouver les moyens d'organiser des temps
de débat d'organiser des temps de
discussion est évidemment que le sujet
de l'ukraine et la situation
internationale va s'inviter en
permanence en permanence et celle
inverse qui serait étonnant sauf que
pour le moment la campagne d'un belgo ne
décolle pas je sais vous voulez pas
regarder les sondages mais quand même
ils sont là vous êtes directrice de
campagne qu'est ce qui ne va pas selon
vos dires de campagne pourquoi ça ne
prend pas écoutez il nous reste d'abord
presque six semaines donc on va
continuer c'est un jeu vous je vous la
corde on va continuer à faire du terrain
on va continuer à défendre nos projets
on va continuer à défendre nos
propositions on va continuer à appeler
les abstentionnistes parce que si vous
faites le cumul des françaises et des
français qui n'ont pas encore choisi
dont le vote n'est pas sûr et de celles
et ceux qui pour l'instant n'ont pas
fait le choix d'une démarche d'aller aux
yeux il reste des françaises et des
français à des formes ce qui est vrai
c'est que plus globalement la gauche a
été dans ce début de campagne
peu audible pour le dire avec un peu de
féminisme peut-être parce que quand la
gauche s'est fragmentée elle est moins
puissante ça fera partie des leçons que
nous on a tiré pour l'avenir ça nous en
parlerons après l'élection
présidentielle
peut-être que globalement la gauche et
aussi à la fin d'un cycle je fais partie
de ceux qui sont assez convaincu de cela
la gauche le parti socialiste les deux
si vous voulez mon avis personnel pour
l'heure le sujet il est à mettre les
propositions sur la table quand anne
hidalgo propose un milliard pour les
violences faites aux femmes quand elles
proposent sur l'urgence sociale
d'augmenter de 200 euros le smic quand
sur l'urgence écologique elle propose et
lisf climatique est ce qu'on appelait le
tiers payant pour la rénovation
énergétique des logements autrement dit
permettre à des gens qui sont prêts à
rénover leur logement parce que c'est
bon pour eux et que c'est bon pour le
climat de pouvoir le faire sans
débourser un euro en sur l'urgence
démocratique elle reprend l'idée du
référendum d'initiative citoyenne je ne
peux croire qu'il n'y aurait que deux
pour cent de gens dans le pays qui
seraient intéressés par ses propositions
encore faut-il que ces sujets que ces
propositions puissent passer le mur du
son et donc c'est ce à quoi nous allons
nous en pots cassés devenu inaudible
selon vous aujourd'hui c'est vrai pour
le ps je le redis c'est globalement vrai
pour la gauche dans sa diversité
nombre de candidats de gauche qui
aujourd'hui ne marche pas et est une
réalité et je crois que nous avons
d'abord à nous imposer dans la bataille
des idées pourquoi j'étais très ferme
tout à l'heure sur le sujet d'eric
zemmour parce qu'au delà du fait que ça
me heurte profondément dans la fibre la
plus humaniste qui est la mienne la
gauche a laissé le début la campagne
monopolisé par des questions imposé par
la droite et l'extrême droite à quel
moment dans ce pays on dit que parler
d'éducation c'est une priorité que
parler de la lutte contre la pauvreté
c'est une priorité que le grand rendez
vous climatique il est devant nous qu'on
ne peut pas s'y dérober la jeunesse de
notre pays nous rappellent en permanence
à nos responsabilités sur ces sujets
mais bon il lui reste six semaines pour
finir de convaincre et je peux vous bien
vente iphone encore temps pour
raccrocher les wagons vous dites la
gauche droite leurs compagnes d'hommes
et de femmes à aller chercher oui j'en
croise tous les ans un moment où
personne n'écoute on est quand même
d'accord je veux dire quand on voit ce
qui se passe en ukraine est ce que les
gens ont la tête à la présidentielle en
france alors qu'il reste six semaines
dont l'inquiétude sur ce qui se passe en
ukraine ils ont aussi l'inquiétude du
quotidien ne nous y trompons pas en
l'inquiétude en ukraine ne chasse pas
donc l'attention nation voire la
s'immobiliser sur les deux tiers sud en
ukraine ne gomme pas la question de
nombreuses françaises des français
comment je fais pour avoir accès à un
généraliste que j'habite dans un grand
et beau quartier populaire où que
j'habite dans un territoire rural donc
oui le débat doit continuer et notre
responsabilité c'est saidal et je suis
en finir sur la gauche alors êtes-vous
dit il faut remettre à plat est ce que
ça veut dire qu'après la présidentielle
ils font au congrès du parti socialiste
il faut aussi remettre en jeu la tête du
ps s'était dit olivier faure je crois
qu'il faudra bien plus qu'un congrès du
parti socialiste mais vous n'aurez
inviterez après les présidentielles pour
en parler on assistera à une
recomposition du paysage politique
français après la présidentielle à lévis
d'abord contre la gauche la france est
soumise le ps allez les verts si on
regarde d'abord celles et ceux qui sont
aujourd'hui
engagé on voit bien qu'on on va y
compris d'un point de vue historique
vers un autre cycle il faut toujours
notre argent à personne que avec
peut-être une alarme c'est qu'il va
partir chez emmanuel macron aussi on
avait marisol touraine on avait les
mêmes niveaux est ce qu'elle m'a partie
des socialismes ans vont partir
franchement pour marisol touraine ou
pour elisabeth guigou s'est pas tout à
fait une surprise ne faisons pas monter
la mayonnaise comme on dit chez moi de
ralliement qui n'ont absolument rien de
nouveau je le redis pour l'instant notre
sujet c'est la présidentielle quand vous
entrez et j'y tiens parce que si on
donne l'impression qu'on s'occupe de la
presse alors qu'il reste six semaines je
ne suis pas sûr que c'est ce qui va
convaincre les françaises et les
français d'aller voter
marisol touraine et d'elisabeth guigou
et ségolène royal qui soutient jean luc
mélenchon qu'est ce que ça vous inspire
franchement c'est triste c'est triste
parce qu'elle a été la candidate de
notre famille politique c'est triste
parce qu'elle a été une des premières
femmes à porter nos couleurs c'est
triste
non franchement non pourquoi d'abord
parce que quand tu joues à voir la
position dure luc mélenchon sur
l'ukraine je trouve absolument
dramatique qu'on puisse dire qu'il
serait le vote utile le vote utile c'est
serait confié les destinées de notre
pays à quelqu'un qui fait si peu de cas
de la responsabilité et de la liberté
quant à ségolène écoutée elle a été
plutôt plus proche de macron ces
dernières années et maintenant plus
proche de mélenchon heureusement il ya
plein d'autres hommes et deux femmes au
ps je peux vous en parler de plein boris
vallot valérie rabault patrick kanner je
le salue quand même nous sommes sur
public sénat je le dis parce que ça veut
dire que dans les quatre coins du pays
est-ouest nord-sud il y a tous les jours
une gauche qui inventent tous les jours
une gauche qui travaillent tous les
jours une gauche qui a assumé totalement
le virage écolo alors cette gauche elle
se bat effectivement les temps ne sont
pas 100 mais elle continue à porter
j'allais presque dire avec honneur les
valeurs auxquelles nous croyons et ce
sera le mot de la fin merci johanna
rolland sans merci beaucoup d'avoir été
notre invité
[Musique]